Mình muốn thương bán ngoại trưởng Iran Abbas Arochi cho biết tên Iran đang sui chỉ hợp tác quân sử dưới nè và Trung Quốc.
Một tả 2,9% này là nhiều lối tác chính là con trọng của Iran.
Pham biểu Trung Quốc phòng vẫn chuyển thân, ông Arochi khẳng định sữa hợp tác giữa các bên dễn xa trên nhiều lĩnh vực.
Mong ngủ chính chỉ, kinh tế và có phòng, sang thông nếu chỉ tiếp của Thay.
Tên bố được đưa ra Trung Quốc cảnh chuyển thông nghị chưa đó, sẫn thông nguyên tinh cho sang,
ngà có thể đã công các thông tin tình báo cho Iran, liên quan đến vị chỉ lực lượng Mỹ tại Trung Đông.
Nhà trắng cho biết đang theo dõi các thông tin này trong khi phía nha bác bỏ cá bộ,
còn Trung Quốc chưa đưa ra bình luận chính thức li bán đề.
Mọi trưởng Iran cũng cho sang, các cô tấn công nhèm vào cơ sử dụng mò chính đào khăn của nước này,
sẽ không làm thuy đổi đáng kể nâng lực xuống khổ nâng hưởng của Thay Iran,
đồng thời i văn kể báo sẽ đáp trả nếu hạ tân nâng lượng của nước này tiếp tục bị tấn công.
Súng đột tại Trung Đông hiện đã bất sang tuần thứ ba với nhiều của tấn công qua lại dưới các bên,
và nguy cơ lan dậu ra toàn khu vực.